[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
it's seven o'clock and this is a Sky
News special program on the Ukraine
Invasion our top story two Grim
Milestones after a week of War
[Music]
Ukraine says 2 000 civilians have now
died and Russia concedes almost 500 of
its troops have been killed
surrounded bombarded and suffering Mass
casualties we report on the city's
hardest hit on day seven of this
conflict
escaping War We join those abandoning
their homes and traveling out of Ukraine
the Chelsea owner Roman Abramovich
confirms he's selling the club amid
growing pressure for London's oligarchs
to lose their assets
here MPS pay their tributes to Ukraine
as the Prime Minister adds his voice to
those accusing Russia of war crimes
and cleared to compete athletes from
Russia and Belarus will be at the
Paralympics but won't be able to fly
their flag
foreign
[Music]
civilians dead 21 of them children these
are sobering numbers released today by
Ukrainian officials a week into Russia's
Invasion for Russia's part it has now
conceded the loss of almost 500 of its
soldiers in battle well day seven of the
war saw Russia intensify its Onslaught
and tighten its grip on some of
Ukraine's major cities Ukrainian
officials say a Russian bombardment in
the eastern city of kharkiv has killed
21 people
Kiev has also been the target of
intensive air and artillery strikes
Ukraine says it shot down two Russian
planes today now that comes after five
people were killed yesterday when the
city's main television Tower and a
Holocaust Memorial were hit
officials in the southern city of Curson
say they were completely surrounded by
Russian Artillery today
while the mayor of Maria Paul which is
in the Southeast reported Mass
casualties earlier
while Russia's defense Ministry says 498
of its troops have now died but as Alex
Rossi now reports the Russian assault
goes on
the attacks are more and more intense
with Russian forces Now using heavy
weapons in civilian areas
in the Second City of kharkiv a
university building crumbles after a
missile strike it's clearly not a
military Target
this place is home to one and a half
million people for those remaining
nowhere is safe even the bomb shelters
their kids at the age of eight ten
eleven twelve and thirteen okay they're
all of them are afraid they will destroy
karki for sure they have no only
people are going to leave Alex's report
bring that to you later because we're
taking this live it's the French
President Emmanuel macron who has spoken
to President Putin in the last couple of
days
of the empires of invasions of
exterminations
violation of the territory and the
sovereignty of the European country
France and Europe responded immediately
unanimously
and firmly we did it in close
coordination with the British the
Canadians the Americans the Japanese and
so many other countries first of all by
supporting the Ukrainian people through
humanitarian convoys and also the
delivery of equipment and materials to
defend themselves and then also by
acting with the other countries so that
the Russian leaders can hear that the
choice of War would in fact put their
country
make sure that their country was against
all the countries and the security
Council United
Nations said that it was violation of
Human Rights and this very afternoon the
general assembly of the United Nations
condemned a buyer
the promote this aggression this attack
and the International Community has
shown solidarity the sports teams in
Russia were excluded from International
uh competitions and a number of sports
events were canceled as well we will
carry on and we will carry on to work in
order to ensure that on all continents
the Nations will condemn The Invasion
insist upon the seafar ceasefire and
also to ensure humanitarian actions in
Ukraine we have very rapidly taken
sanctions set up sanctions with regard
to Russia and its leaders and there are
the assets of hundreds of Russian
personalities have been frozen in France
and abroad a number of major Russian
Banks were excluded from International
payments which meant a number of
transactions were impossible and
the propaganda organs in in Russia have
stopped
emitting in Europe on the ground we've
given the ways to actually protect our
Nationals by organizing the transfer of
our Embassy
to another town in Ukraine and also
allowing all French people whoever
wanted to to be able to leave the
country as soon as possible and hear in
your name I'd like to thank all of the
diplomats police officers military and
estate agents who carry on with this
effort and who are looking after our
citizens in Moldavia and in the main
exit points of the Ukrainian territory
I'd also like to thank her all the
journalists all the journalists that
cover with courage this conflict and
also are trying to ensure the Freedom of
Information for all citizens of the
world finally we have participated in
this effort within the framework of NATO
in order to protect the security and the
sovereignty of our European allies by
reinforcing the military presence that
we already have in the Baltic states and
in the region and among hundreds of
French soldiers arrived yesterday on in
Romania and this was a diplomatic
initiative sanctions against the
political and economic leaders of Russia
supporting the Ukrainian population so
therefore that's going to carry on and
it will be intensified and the aim is to
ensure that combat stops
but at the same time we are not in war
against Russia we all know what
associates us with this major
European population and country that did
so much in order to save Europe enjoying
the second world war So today we're at
the side of all Russians who refused an
undignified war in their name and the
spirit of responsibility and courage of
Defending peace and they certainly
say this in Russia and elsewhere and for
that reason if I constantly talk to the
president zielinski I also chose to keep
in contact and I will keep in contact as
much as possible and as much as
necessary with President Putin in order
to try to find without fail to try to
convince him to give up arms to help him
as much as possible with regard to the
talks underway and also to avoid the
contagion and the increase of this
conflict as much as possible for the
balance
within our continent as with regard to
the number of aspects on a daily uh
basis have been has been unbalanced and
there will be some changes in this
coming months Europe will certainly be
affected by this and I'll come back to
it
there are hundreds of thousands of
refugees coming from Ukraine will be
received on our continent
and are received on our continent and
France will play its own role and I'd
also like to thank our towns and our
villagers that have mobilized and to
thank our charitable organizations
we're also trying to receive these
people and we organize ourselves and we
will take care of those who are coming
to our country to be protected
France will also play its role by
receiving the children who are an exile
separated from their fathers who are
their fighting and we'll do this in
close collaboration with associations
and ngos already offering this in our
country
and our agriculture our industry and a
number of economic sectors are suffering
and will suffer because they depend on
the importation of raw materials from
Russia or Ukraine or because they're
exporting towards those countries and
our growth so today uh will certainly be
perfected and petrol prices gas or
materials of course but this will have a
response will there be some responses
the increase in petrol the increase in
heating the cost of certain products
will in fact go up for sure and so these
economic and social consequences I will
just have what all the only thing I want
to do is to protect him protect you
we're going to of course support uh
certain areas we're going to try to find
new suppliers and certain new outlets
and so with the Americans the Europeans
the people from Middle East we're trying
to work out other Solutions we're trying
to look at the commercial flows and also
an increase of prices and I've asked
prime minister to draw up in the coming
days a plan with regard to economic and
social resilience to be able to respond
to all these difficulties
but let's not be mistaken these events
will not only have immediate
consequences with regards within the
next few weeks they are events that are
signaling a change in our time the war
in Europe no longer belongs to our
history books or our textbooks at school
now we're living this in front of our
eyes democracy is no longer considered
as being uncontestable democracy is
being questioned
and our freedom that of our children is
no longer something that's simply a fact
it's simply a system of courage and it's
a fight of every instant
we're returning to a tragedy in history
and we've got to respond by making
historical decisions our country will
therefore increase investment in defense
and will pursue its a strategy of
Independence and investment in its
economy researcher Innovation
and which has also been already been
reinforced because of the pandemic our
Europe is demonstrating as it has done
in the previous months a remarkable
unity and it now must accept to pay the
price for peace to freedom for democracy
and it must also
invest in order to depend Less on the
other continents and decide for itself
in other words become a more independent
power a more Sovereign power economic
power first of all we can no longer
depend on the others to feed ourselves
to look after ourselves to inform us to
finance ourselves so that's why
with the decisions during the pandemic
we've got to make sure that we promote a
new economic model founded on economic
on Independence and progress as far as
energy is concerned we can no longer
depend on others and we can't depend on
Russian gas in order to heat our homes
and so on so after having decided that
France with regard to development of new
renewable energies and the construction
of new nuclear reactors to defend the
strategy of Independence energetic
Independence and we can no longer depend
on others to offend us whether we're
talking about on the ground at CEO
undersea in the air or in cyber space or
space
and as far as that's concerned our
European Defense must go through a new
state I'll gather together on the 10th
and
11th of uh
March heads of state at a summit which
will decide upon all these matters
and our Europe has demonstrated unity
and determination
and it's entered a new era which we have
to carry on
dear citizens the war in Ukraine Marx
and rupture as well as our continent is
concerned and our generation I know to
what extent it concerns you legitimately
it mobilizes us and we will also mean
that we'll have to take certain
decisions and you realize that this war
is also affecting our Democratic life
and the Electoral campaign that
officially opens at the end of this week
this campaign will allow a democratic
debate which will be important for the
nation but at the same time it won't
stop us from gathering together as far
as Essentials are concerned I'm able to
count on you I know I can count on you
and your attachment to freedom to
equality to fraternity
and to a place of France within the
world
I will never stop defending them and
also
defending those values long live the
republic Long Live France
well that was the French President as
you could see Emanuel macron speaking in
the last few minutes and emphasizing
first and foremost the unity the
unanimity of approach from the West
towards Russia in its invasion of
Ukraine the unity of NATO the the EU and
all the Allies talking then uh
specifically about what France has been
doing about the assets of the oligarchs
Russian oligarchs that it has frozen
just like in the UK uh also talking
about his diplomatic contacts which has
been very important from the point of
view of France you may remember that
Emmanuel macro a couple of weeks ago
went to Moscow and came back from that
meeting with President Putin under the
impression that he had got undertakings
from President Putin not to invade
Ukraine of course that turned out not to
be the case but uh president uh macron
they're saying that he will continue to
talk to president zielinski of Ukraine
and President Putin he will keep those
contacts open very interestingly he also
said there he had to walk back some
comments from his Finance Minister
yesterday Bruno Lemaire who commented
yesterday in in this fraught environment
to perhaps use some unwise words Bruno
Lemaire referred to the all-out economic
and financial war that the West was
carrying out on Russia those comments of
course were were poorly received in
Moscow but uh Emmanuel macron they're
making it very clear he said we are not
at war with Russia we just want them to
stop the violence so uh plenty there to
unpick from the French presidents uh the
main thing being that's it there is a
unanimity continuing unanimity of
approach throughout the West to the
violence in Ukraine carried out by the
Russians and that he will keep those
diplomatic contacts as open as much as
possible
well as we've been hearing it has been
another intense day of fighting a week
into this war just seven days so let's
take a closer look at the movements of
Russian troops on the ground Skies
Kamali Melbourne is at the screen with
the security and defense analyst Michael
Clarke
so we can see Russian forces are arrayed
in many areas around the country Michael
what does this look like uh on day seven
of this conflict well Kamali here we are
on day seven the Russians started with
what I would describe as a plan B they
were trying to do it the way Western
forces would have done it with fast
reasonably lightly armored forces
rushing through the areas to capture
cities and a Dash to Kiev an aerial
assault on care which they tried and
failed to grab the government get the
whole thing over in 72 hours they made a
mess of it the ukrainians are fighting
ferociously and so they've now gone back
to plan A which is what they know how to
do which is a slower moving series of
fronts as the front down the uh nipra
Valley there that you've you've marked
to surround Kiev and the major cities
and take them slowly this has now become
a war of the Cities the ukrainians
didn't have enough troops to to try to
guard the whole country they only
defended the cities quite rightly but
now the Russians are moving in on those
cities and there is a sort of a Northern
war in the southern War as they become
Consolidated they'll then try to join
them up right through the nipra valley
there yeah we'll talk more detail now
about that southern War it's of course
based uh as a jumping off point is
Crimea that was taken by the Russians
back in 2014 and there is fierce
fighting as we understand it for the
city of curacon being contested right
now and for the city of maripol tell us
why those cities are extremely important
Michael yes question is very important
because it's a big Regional City and you
have to hold that if you're going to
create this land Corridor which is now
clearly the objective moving out of the
donbass disputed areas mariopol um
honest unbelievable that should have
fallen within hours and here we are on
day seven and they are still fighting at
maripole according to the Ukrainian
government they are still holding on in
mariopol how they're doing it I don't
know
sooner or later that land Corridor will
be effectively joined up and then we
would expect that Corridor to go towards
Odessa the the ancient uh Port of uh
Ukraine and so that Corridor will
continue on westwards and then start to
push northwards up the nipra valley in
order to link up with forces that by
then probably will have taken care of
those forces that are pushing down from
the north let's just take a look again
at The Wider map of Ukraine Michael
because of course in the past 24 hours
and for the past week or so there have
been calls to the west to do more
sanctions of a course in place but there
are calls for a no-fly zone and there
have been calls in the past few hours
for a humanitarian Corridor which is How
likely are any of those things do you
think at this point humanitarian
Corridor is plausible not easy at the
moment but a humanitarian Corridor on
the ground with some sort of U.N
supervision or supervision from the
organization of security and cooperation
in Europe that's plausible to have
ground corridors no fly zones is a
non-starter because the way no-fly zones
have to work is that aircraft have to
attack anti-aircraft and radar stations
on the ground and one thing that will
not happen is NATO aircraft attacking
Russian anti-aircraft and radar stations
that have now established themselves on
the ground in Ukraine that's a recipe
for war we're not going to do it
now the owner of Chelsea Football Club
Roman Abramovich has confirmed that he
is actively looking now to sell the club
it's seen of course as a preemptive move
amid growing calls for London's Super
Rich oligarchs to be stripped of their
assets today during prime minister's
questions labor urged the government to
introduce harder and tougher sanctions
our Deputy political editor Sam coats
reports now on the oligarchs being
targeted
solidarity Unity respect
rare Applause from MPS as the House of
Commons roses won to the Ukrainian
ambassador
he and the country heard the strongest
condemnation yet from Boris Johnson what
we have seen already from Vladimir
Putin's regime in the use of the
Munitions that they have already been uh
they've been dropping on as on innocent
civilians uh Mr Speaker in my view
already fully qualifies as as a war cram
but its actions not words demanded by
the labor leader what about the owner of
Chelsea Football Club Roman Abramovich
he's a person of interest to the home
office because of his links to the
Russian State and his public association
with corrupt activity and practices
last week the Prime Minister said that
Abramovich is facing sanctions he later
corrected the record to say that he
isn't
well why on Earth isn't he there's more
to come says Boris Johnson what we will
publish in addition uh Mr Speaker is a
full list of all those Associated uh
with the Putin regime the vice is
tightening on the Putin regime and it
will continue to tighten calls came from
all sides to do more even using the
legal protections of parliament to list
possible targets I don't want war nobody
wants War
but we're not even
sanctioning Sergey shoigu the Russian
defense minister yet
no Igor osipov the commander of the
Black Sea Fleet aura's manov section
peskov Abramovich Roald Dugan or the
members of the Russian Duma who voted
for this war
at Prime Minister's questions kirstama
said that Two Flats in here worth 11
million pounds and just a few hundred
yards from Downing Street are owned by
an ally of Vladimir Putin Igor chavalov
is on the EU sanctions list but not on
the British one kistana asked why now
officials say that cases involving
Russian oligarchs are tricky they take
time they don't want to end up making
mistakes and in court but pressure is
building on all sides to fill the gaps
in the sanctions regime
tonight the oligarch sell-off begins
Roman Abramovich announced he is selling
Chelsea Football Club thought to be
asking 4 billion pounds for it and
promising the proceeds will go to the
victims of the Ukraine conflict more
sanctions are coming more sell-offs
likely unpicking a three-decade
relationship with modern Russia in haste
samcoat Sky News Westminster
well now the United Nations General
Assembly overwhelmingly voted to condemn
Russia for its invasion of Ukraine today
the UN also demanded that Russia stops
the attack and withdraws its troops in
total 141 Nations supported the motion
and only five including Belarus opposed
it
for those who remain Russia is
destroying critical infrastructure vital
Services which provide millions of
people across Ukraine with drinking
water to stay alive gas to keep people
from freezing to death
and now it appears Russia is preparing
to increase the brutality of its
campaign against Ukraine
we've seen videos of Russian forces
moving exceptionally lethal Weaponry
into Ukraine which has no place on the
battlefield
that includes cluster Munitions and
vacuum bombs which are banned under the
Geneva Convention
let's talk to our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone and Mark very clearly Russia has
precious few friends left at the U.N
yes a chamber that exposed those uh who
are sticking by their old Ally Russia
just four countries uh plus Russia voted
against this resolution they are North
Korea Eritrea Syria and Belarus
um clearly countries that you would
expect to vote this way the abstentions
were interesting for their own
geopolitical calculations 34 countries
decided to abstain among them Cuba China
India Kazakhstan Zimbabwe another number
of other African nations as well I think
within those group of upstanding Nations
uh perhaps that is the Avenue for
diplomacy we know that the Chinese
Premier sorry the Chinese foreign
minister Wang Yi spoke to the Ukrainian
foreign minister over the past 24 hours
the Ukrainian foreign minister has also
spoken to the Indian foreign minister
now both China and India have close
diplomatic relations with the Russians
as does Israel Israel's prime minister
has been speaking to both sides if there
is an attempt to find a diplomatic
solution here then does it come from one
of those Avenues perhaps and I think
certainly officials within the United
Nations have been stressing that
diplomacy is the only answer but but as
a message of of isolation uh it was one
heck of a message that the screen that
went up in the U.N security Council
showing all those countries voting with
this for this resolution uh
non-non-binding not legal but a clear
message and just so few uh voting
against um so that is that uh Dermot
here in Washington we've had some more
updates as we had get every day from the
Department of Defense the um uh Pentagon
here they say now that 82 percent of the
forces that Vladimir Putin committed to
Ukraine that were that were mounting On
the Border are now inside Ukraine
um so very few
um still a large number but a small
percentage left on the Russian side 450
missiles have now been fired they have
been struck at the Pentagon at how
little artillery has been used in a
convention additional invasion of a
country the first thing you would do is
fire an awful lot of artillery from your
side of the border into the country
you're invading the Russians haven't
done that now the Russians are saying
that's because we're trying to prevent
civilian casualties the the honest the
truth is that there are many civilian
casualties but for one reason or another
they haven't been using the artillery
that might have been expected I suppose
that has perhaps reduced the number of
Civilian deaths that we could have seen
although the Americans are quite clear
that civilians are being hit in in
relatively large numbers and we've seen
the evidence of that as for that column
of armored vehicles of Russian armored
vehicles 40 kilometers 40 miles long
heading towards Kiev it is still stalled
so say the Americans they believe there
are Supply problems food and fuel
problems as well or other Russians just
regrouping to try and move in at another
point the Americans just don't know on
that one okay
yeah I think Mark was just about to tell
us so that your secretary state Anthony
blinken is giving us an update so let's
listen
the assault continues by land uh by air
by sea and as I noted in my remarks uh
at the un uh Human Rights Council just
yesterday
Russian strikes are hitting schools
hospitals
residences
they're destroying critical
infrastructure which supplies millions
of people across Ukraine with drinking
water with electricity with gas to keep
from freezing to death
buses
cars ambulances
being shelled
yesterday
Russian strikes in Kiev struck the
capital's main television and radio
tower
and destroyed part of the babiyar
Holocaust Memorial
apartment buildings outside of Kiev were
hit
partially collapsed
a huge explosion occurred in the main
square of kharkiv Ukraine's second
largest city
these aren't military targets
they are places where civilians work
and families live
archiva is one of the largest
russian-speaking cities in Europe
it's fewer than 50 miles from Belgrade
its sister city in Russia
and Belgrade is where the missiles
against harkiv were likely fired
President Putin among the many
uh
false justifications
he's given for invading Ukraine has
cited the need to protect against an
imaginary threat
to Russian ethnic and russian-speaking
peoples
how is assaulting and bombing
the population of harkiv
again one of the largest
russian-speaking cities in Europe
advancing that purported goal
as president zielinski said after the
assault
uh there was never a border between
kharkiv and its Russian sister city
uh two cities are are joined in the
hearts of Ukrainian and Russian people
living on either side
among the
great damage we see from War uh we're
seeing that uh in in our keep
we've also seen that
the international court of justice has
announced that it will hold hearings
on Russia's actions
already the human costs of the Kremlin
is unwarranted
unprovoked and unjustified war on
Ukraine
are staggering
hundreds if not thousands of civilians
have been killed and wounded
there are now more than 174 000 refugees
who've sought safety in nearby countries
millions of ukrainians still in Ukraine
are Sheltering wherever they can
including children receiving cancer
treatment
who are now living in the basements of
Ukraine's Children's Hospitals with
doctors and nurses doing their best to
care for them as explosions boom
overhead
this is shameful
the numbers of civilians killed and
wounded the humanitarian consequences
will only grow in the days ahead
in the face of this violence the courage
of the Ukrainian people
is inspiring the world
as President Biden said in the State of
the Union Address last night
the response to Russia's War has been
Unity
Unity among world leaders
unity in Europe
Unity among people gathering around the
world
to protest President Putin's war of
choice
including thousands of people in Russia
and Belarus coming out to protest
peacefully even though they know what
they risk in so doing
because the Biden Administration
dedicated its first year
to repairing and rebuilding our
alliances and Partnerships in Europe and
around the world
and because we spent the better part of
the past several months
raising alarms about looming Russian
aggression
declassifying and sharing our
intelligence nearly in real time and
relentlessly exposing President Putin's
lies
we were ready
in fact one reason why we're seeing the
unified response now is because we made
the decision late last year to publicize
to the world what we knew was underway
and the Playbook we were convinced
Russia would follow
I went to the U.N security Council two
weeks ago to walk through step by step
the pretext for war that we were sure
President Putin would invent
and the subsequent military invasion
that he planned to order
that's precisely what he did
while Russian officials continue to deny
it right until the invasion began
seeing that duplicity and premeditated
aggression play out exactly as we'd
predicted
has generated outrage and solidarity
across Europe and around the world
and that's turned into unprecedented
action
we said that if the Kremlin ordered an
invasion we would help Ukraine defend
itself
while imposing costs on Russia
last week the president approved 350
million dollars in military assistance
to Ukraine to help with the armored
airborne and other significant threats
it now faces
that brings our total security
assistance to Ukraine in the past year
to more than one billion dollars more
than in any previous year
over the past several days I authorized
the expedited transfer of U.S origin
defensive equipment from allies to
Ukraine and we're coordinating efforts
to get this equipment including
anti-tank and anti-aircraft Weaponry as
well as small arms and Munitions into
the hands of Ukrainian fighters who are
defending their country with skill and
determination
we're sending humanitarian assistance to
the people of Ukraine as well
three days ago we announced nearly 54
million dollars in additional support on
top of the more than 300 million dollars
that we provided in recent years usaid
has deployed a Disaster Assistance
Response Team our top International
emergency responders to lead the US
humanitarian response in coordination
with European allies partners and
international organizations and usaid
director Samantha power was as you know
just uh in Poland along the border with
Ukraine a few days ago along with other
senior officials from the state
department
and we're working to support the front
line countries including Poland Moldova
Romania Hungary and Slovakia that have
welcomed hundreds of thousands of
refugees including many children elderly
people people with disabilities all of
whom are fleeing Ukraine to escape
Russia's violence and facing harrowing
Journeys to reach safety
we and our allies and partners will work
to keep people safe
manage the flow of refugees
keep border crossings open and provide
critical supplies
at the same time
we're holding Russia accountable
including Russia's economy
back on December 1st
I said that Russia would face massive
consequences for attacking Ukraine
including severe and Lasting economic
costs
the United States and more than 30
allies and partners representing more
than half the world's economy have made
good on that commitment with powerful
sanctions and Export controls on Russia
including additional actions just today
we've now sanctioned most of Russia's
largest financial institutions and its
Sovereign wealth fund
the European Union removed key
sanctioned Russian Banks from the Swift
International payments Network
we've restricted Russia's ability to
seek funding Beyond its borders
13 of the most critical Russian
state-owned Enterprises including
gasprom are now extremely Limited in
raising money through the U.S market
we've imposed sanctions on individuals
including President Putin other members
of Russia's Security Council and Elites
and their family members
and we and our allies and partners are
launching a task force
to identify track down and freeze the
assets of sanctioned Russian companies
and oligarchs we will freeze and seize
their Yachts their private jets their
opulent Estates in world capitals
today we're also imposing sweeping
sanctions on Russia's defense sector
in total 22 Russian defense related
entities will be designated
including companies that make combat
aircraft
infantry fighting Vehicles missiles
unmanned aerial Vehicles electronic
warfare systems the very systems now
being used to assault the Ukrainian
people abuse human rights violate
International humanitarian law
we're also posing export controls on
Belarus
to hold the likashenka regime
accountable for being a co-belligerent
in President Putin's war of choice
we will choke off yellowrose's ability
to import key Technologies
and if lukashank is support for the war
continues
the consequences for his regime
will escalate
all told
these sanctions and restrictions have
had a powerful effect on Russia's
economy
the value of the ruble has plummeted
the Russian stock market closed at a
sphere of capital flight Rose
interest rates more than doubled
Russia's credit rating has been cut to
junk status
the value of President Putin's War fund
has vanished
and by choking Russia's access to
technology
we're delivering a blow to its economy
and Military that will be felt not just
now
but for years to come
President Putin may have assumed that
the United States and our allies
were bluffing when we warned a massive
unprecedented consequences
but as President Biden likes to say
big Nations can't Bluff
the United States doesn't Bluff and
President Putin has Gravely
miscalculated
as President Biden made clear last night
this is President Putin's War
this isn't the Russian people's War
it's becoming clear by the day
that the Russian people oppose it
members of the Russian military oppose
it and had no idea
what they were being sent to do
and now the Russian people will suffer
the consequences of their leaders
choices
so my message to the people of Russia if
they're even able to hear it as the
Kremlin cracks down even harder on media
Outlets reporting the truth
my message is that we know
many of you want no part of this war
you like ukrainians like Americans like
people everywhere want the same basic
things
good jobs
clean air and water
the chance to raise your kids in safe
neighborhoods to send them to good
schools to give them better lives than
you had
how in the world does President Putin's
unprovoked aggression against Ukraine
help you achieve any of these things
how is it going to make your lives
better
the economic costs that we've been
forced to impose on Russia are not aimed
at you
they're aimed at compelling your
government to stop its actions to stop
its aggression
and just as millions of us around the
world Stand Together against moscow's
aggression we also stand together with
you as you demand
that your leaders end this war
if President Putin wants to demonstrate
leadership
he should allow Russian soldiers to go
home to their families
finally
the United States is continuing our
diplomatic efforts
we're keeping the door open
to a diplomatic Way Forward
that's going to be very hard to happen
without military de-escalation
it's much more difficult for diplomacy
to succeed when guns are firing tanks
are rolling planes are flying
but
if Russia pulls back and pursues
diplomacy
We Stand ready to do the same thing
meanwhile
our intensive diplomacy with allies and
partners continues
I've been in virtually daily contact
with my my friend and counterpart
Ukraine's foreign minister kaleba
and I've made clear that we'll support
any diplomatic efforts by the Ukrainian
government to reach a ceasefire and
withdrawal of Russian forces
if there are diplomatic steps that we
can take that the Ukrainian government
believes would be helpful we're prepared
to take them even as we continue to
support Ukraine's ability to defend
itself
tomorrow I'll travel to Brussels where
I'll meet with our NATO European union
and G7 allies and partners to continue
our coordination
to commend them on the unprecedented
steps that they've taken to support
Ukraine and hold Russia to account
and to reaffirm our article 5 commitment
that an attack on any NATO member is an
attack on all
uh from there I'll travel to Poland
which is already hosting hundreds of
thousands of Ukrainian refugees uh with
tens of thousands arriving by the day
and then to Moldova which is also
hosting Ukrainian refugees and where
Russian troops have been occupying
territory against the will of the people
for years
uh and then I'll go on to the Baltic
countries to Latvia Lithuania Estonia
which are facing A Renewed threat from
Russia themselves as President Putin
seeks to reassert Russia's dominance
over former Soviet Republics
Lafayette Lithuania Estonia are our NATO
allies
and as President Biden has said we will
defend every inch of NATO territory
against any aggression from Russia or
otherwise
finally
I want to note the consequential and
historic vote that just took place in
the United Nations
141 member states
voted in favor of a resolution
reaffirming Ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity and condemning
Russia's invasion of another member
state
as this vote revealed the overwhelming
majority of the International Community
stands in strong support of the core
principles of the United Nations and
upholding the U.N Charter
and stands against Russia's Reckless
attempts to change the borders of
another sovereign country by force to
replace its will for the will of the
Ukrainian people
as 141 member states of the United
Nations know
more is at stake even than the conflict
in Ukraine itself and the freedom of
security of Ukraine and its people
this is a threat to stability in Europe
and to the entire rules-based order
which has been the foundation of
security and prosperity for people
around the world for nearly 80 years
in this time of uncertainty
we have a clear Way Forward
help Ukraine defend itself
support the Ukrainian people
hold Russia accountable
and persist with diplomacy
President Putin is more isolated from
the world than ever before
as President Biden predicted last night
when the history of this era is written
Russia's war on Ukraine will have left
Russia weaker
and the rest of the world stronger
and in the days ahead
we'll continue to draw inspiration
from the Iron Will of the Ukrainian
people
with that happy to take some questions
thanks for being here
um I just want to ask you what is the
U.S assessment on Putin's State of Mind
you said that he's more isolated than
before
do you worry that this isolation might
prompt him to lash out and do something
even more dramatic than we've so far
seen on the ground and I also want to
ask you I'm sure you've seen that there
are Americans who have expressed their
desire to go and join the fights in
Ukraine what is your message to them
thanks
um I can't
put myself in in President Putin's uh
mind or or state of mind
um
all that that we can focus on are the
actions uh that he's taking and our
response to those actions
um
I I said before one of the
Achilles heels of autocracies
is
the inability to speak truth to power
I don't know who said what to President
Putin before he launched this aggression
I don't know who's saying what to him
now
um
but again all of that is
um is speculation uh we can't put
ourselves in his mindset uh all we can
do is what we're doing which is to be
very clear in how we'll uh respond to
the actions that he takes
to continue to work in unity with allies
and partners in support of Ukraine in
defense of Ukraine to help its people to
host to help those who've been forced to
flee uh and if there are any diplomatic
opportunities to pursue to pursue those
uh but we're focused uh Less on what
President Putin thinks or may think and
more on what he does
um and with regard to the second part of
your question look we've been uh very
clear for some time of course in calling
on Americans who may be may have been
resident in Ukraine uh to leave and
making clear to Americans who may be
thinking of traveling there not to go
for those who want to help Ukraine
um and help his people there are many uh
ways to do that including by uh
supporting and helping the many ngos
that are working to provide humanitarian
assistance uh providing resources
themselves to uh to groups that are
trying to help Ukraine by being
advocates
uh for for Ukraine uh and uh and for a
peaceful resolution
uh to this crisis that was created by uh
by Russia those are the most effective
ways that the people who want to help
can do so
Mr secretary
you just voted the president saying big
Nations don't Bluff
do you think that President Putin is
bluffing by putting his nuclear forces
on alert
and I had another question if you don't
mind
are you surprised that we have not seen
more
we've seen some denial of services but
are you surprised that we have not seen
a more massive Cyber attack against
Ukraine or against other of the the NATO
Nations or against us
do you think that the legislation that
just passed improves our ability to
defend against such attacks and if I
could
impose on you one more question I talked
today to Daria glenyak who was part of
the president in your democracy
Summit this year
and you know how passionate she is
perhaps you saw her questioning and she
says that despite everything that has
been done and
I would I would say it's an
extraordinary amount of coordination and
agreement with the Allies it's not going
to get there in time that Convoy is
sitting outside Kiev
and poised to encircle with you and
they're not going to get those supplies
what more can be done to help those
people
Andrew thank you
um let me take them in uh not quite
reverse order uh first just on the uh
the Cyber piece uh two things first yes
the legislation that you refer to is
extremely helpful
but beyond that and before that
we have been very focused on the
potential for uh cyber attacks not only
against Ukraine but against us against
allies and partners we've been working
for months first with Ukraine and also
among ourselves uh to uh to harden to
sharpen defenses all of that work is
very much underway including with the
private sector and so I think we have to
be very much on guard about that that
possibility we are
um
with regard to assistance to Ukraine
here's what I can here's what I can tell
you
we are
very actively working
every day every hour to provide that
assistance and to
um
make sure that to the best of our
ability it gets to where it needs to go
and this is not just us this is many
countries in Europe
we're coordinating a lot of efforts to
do that and my own assessment right now
is that the vitally needed assistance is
getting to where it needs to go
um with regard to President Putin's
statements on Russia's nuclear posture
uh first as you know
Russia and the United States have long
agreed
that the actual use of nuclear weapons
would be devastating and have
devastating consequences
for the entire world
and as we've stated many times including
earlier this year following the meeting
between President Biden and President
Putin in Geneva
um both of our countries have stated
that a nuclear war cannot be won and
must never be fought
that was a key reaffirmation coming out
of the meeting between President Biden
and President Putin back in June
provocative rhetoric about uh nuclear
weapons
is the height of your responsibility
um
it's dangerous
it adds to the risk of miscalculation
it needs to be avoided
we've assessed President Putin's
directive and his statements
and at this time we see no reason to
change our own alert levels
thanks amen Mr secretary thank you um I
I you mentioned the vote in the U.N
which was by you know it was
overwhelming as as you said and the the
countries that voted against the five
countries who voted against no surprise
Belarus Eritrea and North Korea Syria
and Russia but I'm wondering if you have
any thoughts about the abstentions
particularly from Latin America Cuba
Nicaragua Venezuela who stayed out these
are countries that are no stranger to
larger Powers might shall go unnamed
getting involved in in their internal
policy I'm wondering if that says
anything to you and then secondly
um on the prospects for diplomacy with
Russia which you said you're keeping the
door open to I mean
really what are the what are the
prospects for what are the chances of
that happening in our and and and is
there
if there is an Open Door is it just for
Ukraine uh and potentially the Iran
talks in Vienna or are you open to
the whole gamut of things the arms
control
climate all you know any number of other
things thank you
um Matt first of all to put the the vote
in the U.N
um in perspective
um it is
both overwhelming and I would even say
historic uh go back to 2014. when the
general assembly pronounced itself on
Russia's initial aggression against
Ukraine the votes in favor of that
resolution were 100.
um then go to uh the horrific actions
that the Assad regime took uh in Aleppo
the vote there was 120 in favor of a
resolution uh condemning the actions of
the the Assad regime
today
141 votes
um that speaks powerfully and eloquently
about
the overwhelming majority of the world
and its views about what Russia is doing
in Ukraine
uh I'm not going to parse the the the
the individual votes I think
um
in some cases an abstention actually
speaks loudly itself
um as opposed to a no vote
um so I think you have to look at some
of the individual countries uh assess
their relationship with Russia and and
look at how they voted in in that
context
for the small number
that voted against
Belarus
the dprk Eritrea Syria as well as of
course Russia
as
Groucho Marx once sort of said this is
not very much a club that I would want
to be a member of
oh wait sorry and the prospects were
deployed oh I'm sorry yes
um
look as I said
a moment ago with regard to Ukraine
itself
we of course uh reunion open to pursuing
any reasonable path but it's very hard
to see any path when the bonds are
dropping the planes are flying the tanks
are rolling so de-escalation pulling
back forces that would open a path to uh
to diplomacy and and we I think
demonstrated very clearly in the in the
months leading up to Russia's aggression
that we were prepared to engage Russia
diplomatically on uh any legitimate
security concerns on a reciprocal basis
that remains unfortunately
tragically horrifically I think we've
seen and you don't have to take my word
for it just listen to President Putin's
own words
that virtually everything the Russian
government professed
to be concerned about was not really
what was at issue for example Ukraine
joining NATO but President Putin has
said loudly and clearly and has now
demonstrated by the actions that Russia
has taken is that what this is about
for him
is
Ukraine being absorbed in one fashion or
another into Russia
he sees Ukraine as having no independent
existence
he wants to
reincorporate it into uh into an Empire
short of that to make it part of a
renewed sphere of influence
or maybe at the very least
uh to uh to make it totally uh neutral
so this is about
way more than the
issues that we were
prepared to engage Russia so two two
quick pieces on the diplomacy now one
with regard to Ukraine itself first and
foremost uh the the question is if
Ukraine thinks there is a path that
would help Advance its interests protect
it and the war and we can be helpful in
that of course we're fully prepared to
do that but we really look to the
Ukrainian government to see what what if
anything might make sense uh they're in
engaged in uh in talks with with Russia
they had one round there may be another
one we'll see
um but of course the uh the demands that
Russia put on the table uh were uh
Beyond excessive they were of course
non-starters and what we've seen
repeatedly is that Russia goes through
the pretense of diplomacy to distract
and continue uh it on its aggressive
path
um more broadly
even as we've imposed
um and continue to impose massive costs
on Russia for its aggression and actions
in Ukraine if we determine that there
are areas that it's in our interests
to continue to pursue and that in one
fashion or other may involve some
engagement from Russia uh we'll continue
to pursue that we're not going to let
Russia dictate in any way what's in our
interests and how to pursue them
media Ukraine um just a few days ago
European Union proposed to donate their
fighter jets to Ukraine to protect our
sky but as far as they know for now this
deal has fallen apart I know know that
you were in a phone call with foreign
minister Colima today discussing that
this topic as well could one expect that
after after your travel to Europe
something could change and Ukraine will
get access to those Jets
thank you
um I I can't comment in detail in my
conversations with foreign minister
kaleba we uh we talked about a lot of
things including
the ongoing provision of security
assistance to uh to Ukraine and that is
something that I will be talking to
European allies and uh and partners
about in a couple of days in in Brussels
uh again I can tell you is
I mentioned in response to Andrea's
question that when it comes to vital uh
defensive military equipment that that
Ukraine needs we are very actively
coordinating its provision and that
assistance is uh is getting there but
we'll probably have more to say in the
next couple of days thank you thank you
very much thanks everyone
well uh an important address there uh by
the U.S Secretary of State Anthony
blinken just taking one more question
let's hear it we've certainly seen uh in
the past that um one of Russia's methods
of War uh is
to be absolutely brutal
in trying to
cow the citizenry of
um of a given country and that includes
at the very least
indiscriminate
targeting
and potentially deliberate targeting as
well we're looking very closely at
what's happening in Ukraine right now
including what's happening to uh to
civilians
we're taking account of it we're
documenting it and we want to ensure
among other things
that there's accountability for it
your secretary state Anthony blinken
they're making some very sober measured
and direct comments about the Russian
aggression the invasion of Ukraine quick
thoughts from our U.S correspondent Mark
Stone in Washington on that marker what
stood out for you
well there are a couple of news lines uh
new things that we learned but much of
it was a reflection on what has happened
and an assessment of where things are
now in terms of the new lines he did
talk about new sanctions against
specifically against the Russian defense
industry that would be coming into play
play very very soon and some sweeping
sanctions on Belarus as well of course
Russia's accomplice in this um in this
Invasion uh sanctions against Belarus
that will be increased over the coming
days if it does not separate itself from
this Russian Adventure into Ukraine he
had a message too for the uh for the
Russian people he said this isn't a uh
we are not targeting you we are
targeting uh your leadership and he also
made clear that he wouldn't be drawn on
President Putin's State of Mind
okay Mark Stone in Washington thank you
very much indeed
and uh it is coming up to eight o'clock
and you're watching a Sky News special
program on the Ukraine Invasion uh the
top story is two Grim Milestones after a
week so far of War
[Music]
Ukraine says 2 000 civilians have now
died and Russia concedes almost 500 of
its troops have been killed
surrounded bombarded and suffering Mass
casualties we report on the city's
hardest hit on day seven of this
conflict
the Chelsea Football Club owner Roman
Abramovich confirms he's selling the
club amid growing pressure for London's
oligarchs to lose their assets
[Music]
a tribute to Ukraine is the prime
minister adds his voice to those
accusing Russia of war crimes
and cleared to compete athletes from
Russia and Belarus will be at the
Paralympics but will not be able to fly
their flag
[Music]
a very good evening 2 000 civilians dead
21 of them children well these are
sobering numbers released today by
Ukrainian officials a week into Russia's
Invasion Russian officials said today
that almost 500 of its troops have been
killed in the conflict
well day seven of the war saw Russia
intensify its own slaught and tighten
its grip on major cities Ukrainian
officials say a Russian bombardment in
the eastern city of khakive has killed
21 people
Kiev has also been the target of
intensive air and artillery attacks
Ukraine says it shot down two Russian
aircraft today
it comes after five people were killed
yesterday when the city's main
television Tower and the Holocaust
Memorial were hit officials in the
southern city of Castle said they were
completely surrounded by Russian
Artillery today while the mayor of Maria
Paul which is in the Southeast reported
Mass casualties earlier
while Russia's defense Ministry says 498
of its troops have now died but as Alex
Rossi now reports from the city of
junipro the Russian assault goes on
the attacks are more and more intense
with Russian forces Now using heavy
weapons in civilian areas
in the Second City of kharkiv a
university building crumbles after a
missile strike it's clearly not a
military Target
this place is home to one and a half
million people for those remaining
nowhere is safe even the bomb shelters
they are kids at the age of eight ten
eleven twelve and thirteen okay they're
all of them are afraid they will destroy
karkey for sure they have no limits they
have no moral they have no one human